[Music]
Christian
hello
everyone
hi hello hello
hello um my name is Abby salsman um I
know many of you not everyone though um
we have some very exciting announcement
in the fact that today is youth
Sunday so Michael Marissa Maggie and I
are the you leaders of our youth program
um so the whole service tonight is going
to be led by our youth team which is
pretty exciting so this is your first
time you're in for a treat um we do have
a bunch of announcements though
obviously leading up to Easter there's a
lot of things moving around so bear with
me I don't normally read off the phone
but here we go so first off next week is
going to be Palm Sunday here 5 o'l
normal routine for church uh we'll do a
little parade around the building and
everything so please make sure you show
up uh the following Friday is going to
be good Friday um we're going to be
joining saxi first for their Good Friday
canata style musical service at 700 p.m.
on that Friday um after that um this is
the most important probably announcement
of them all is that our Easter Service
is actually going to be on Saturday
night um we're going to have a service
from 5:00 to 6:00 p.m. on Saturday March
30th uh we're going to do a potluck meal
AKA soup bread and dessert to follow the
service at the Family Life Center so in
the building itself back in the gym um
there is a sign up um I don't think it's
on the announcements but there's a sign
up online if you're going to be
attending the potluck so we obviously
want to make sure that everybody there's
enough food for everybody um also our
kids ministry is requesting donations of
pre-stuffed Easter eggs uh for our kids
Easter egg hunt on that Easter Saturday
uh those can be dropped off with any of
the kids ministry team workers or at the
kids check-in table when you come in um
two of The Sundays leading up to Easter
um last thing obviously before uh we get
into this worship team which was very
exciting um we just want to prepare
ourselves um I know it's uh been a busy
week many of you are coming back from
Spring Breaks with the kids some of
people are dealing with sickness because
of all of the traveling and moving
around um we just kind of want to get in
the right head space to begin our
service so um will you pray with me for
John the Baptist preparing the way by
repentance and baptism we thank you for
Jesus Christ proclaimed your son by
water and spirit we thank you for good
news that salvation has come to the
Earth we thank you for your love
undeserved and graciously given we thank
[Music]
you all right as we wow as we enter in
to our worship I'm inviting you guys to
stand up um we're going to introduce
ourselves um I'm Eden and Eve is on
Cahone and I have Maggie on keys and
Michael on guitar um so we're just going
to start with our very first
[Music]
song
I searched the
world it couldn't fill
me and empty praise Treasures pain
never then you came
along put me back
together and every desire is now
satisfied he in you
love oh there's
nothing better than you there's
nothing better than you or there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you
I'm Not
[Music]
Afraid show you my
weakness my failures and FL Lord You'
seen the more and you still call me
friend cu the god of the
mountain is the god out of the
[Applause]
valley there's not a place for Mercy
Grace won't find me
[Music]
again oh
there's better than you there's
nothing better than you oh there's
nothing nothing is better than
you oh there's
nothing better than you there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you you took morning to
dancing you give Beauty for
Ashes you turn shame into
Glory you're the only one who
came you turn Graves into
Gard you turn those into
our you turn SE into
highways you're the only one who
cares oh there's
nothing better than you oh there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better than
you oh there's
nothing better than you oh there's
nothing better than you there's
nothing nothing is better than
[Music]
you you turn morning to
dancing you give Beauty for
ases
you turn shame into
Glory you're the only one who
can you turn Graves into
Gardens you turn bones into
armies you turn spe into
highways you're the only one who
can you're the only one who
can you're the only
one so this um next moment we're going
to let the kiddos exit to their teachers
and um find their
classrooms and in here we're going to
transition to a tradition that we have
in this moment of our service losing my
mic there I don't know um I'll just keep
talking though um we're g to um
transition to prayers of the people and
this is a time that we um want to make
space to acknowledge what we're carrying
into the room I heard it said one time
um if you were getting on an airplane
what baggage do you have with you and
this is just a moment that we take to
acknowledge that before God so that we
don't ever walk into this place needing
to feel like we have to put on airs or
you know act a certain way um when you
know we want our outward expression to
reflect what's going on inside as well
so um I'm going to have Eve walk us
through prayers of the people if you
guys would follow her as she leads us um
the words will be on the
screen for the City saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
poor and the impressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and for those unjustly
targeted for their gender sexuality race
or other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you you may share your request
privately
[Music]
the names and the moments we' have
spoken out loud and for those we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have Life Light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
amen
in my
mother you for me with your hands known
in Love by
you before I took a breath when I doubt
it Lord me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist and
water of the canvas and
cl you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory
and for your
name it's for your
name there's a healing
light just beyond the cloud though I
walk through
fire as see clear
I know nothing has
beened you're in arst
the the canvas and the
CL you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good
you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name for your
name
[Music]
[Applause]
doub Lord remind me I wonderfully
made
arst I'm the cand and the clay I no
nothing has been wasted no failure
mistake you're AR
and I'm the and
the you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together together For Your Glory
[Music]
for I wonder ful
made artist and a I'm the C and the CL I
know nothing has been wasted no
failure arst and a part on the can
[Music]
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me no you're
not finished with me
[Music]
yet you make all
things were
together for my
[Music]
future and for my good you make all
things work
together
For Your
Glory and for your
[Music]
name worthy of every song we could ever
sing Worthy of all the praise we could
ever
bring worthy of every breath we could
ever breathe we live for you oh we live
for
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could ever
SA
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for you oh we live for
you
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and joy
me who you are and fill me with your
heart and Lead
Me Love to
those around
[Music]
me worthy of every song song we could
ever
sing worthy of all the praise we could
bring worthy of all the we could ever
breathe we live for you oh we live for
you Jesus the name above every other
name
Jesus the only one who could ever
save worthy of every breath we could
ever breathe we live for you oh we live
for
you
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
love
to sing Holy
Holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
wonder
show me who you are and fill me with
your heart and Le me in your love to
those around
[Music]
me love around
me I will be build my life upon your
love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen
holy there is no one like you you there
is none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love to those around
me bow your heads with me
please
Lord thank you so much that we're
allowed to gather here today and
celebrate you
together please open our hearts to the
wisdom that we might collect from the
youth tonight um you know how much I
love them and how much this community
loves them and I'm so happy that we get
to Showcase all that they have to say
tonight we love you Lord we love these
kids and we love being together in Jesus
name we pray
[Music]
amen
um turn and greet the people
around
all right hello hello is it
on do y'all hear me is
it yeah green light is
on hello hello all right we can just
start okay so I am there we go
um hi my name is Eden um and I'm aor
at Alan high school and um we're going
to get into some questions here with um
Eve and Hank but I just wanted to
introduce myself um and then we'll go
around and introduce ourselves together
so um I joined the table about well in
person about a year and a half ago um my
pronouns are he him and um I attend
Allen High School where um I do choir
and then Hank um I'll give it to you all
right uh my name is Hank humble uh I've
been coming here since about I think
late
2020 um I'm a junior in high school and
um I really like
art um hi my name is Eve Tilford um I'm
a freshman at saxi high school I do swim
team and volleyball outside of school
and um my dad actually started the
church so I've been coming here since it
started
right so um we have been talking um the
last semester so since January um about
a few topics um and mainly they've been
consisting of Romans 14 and um 1
Corinthians 8 so um before we get into
any questions regarding in those um I
would like to give you all context
basically for what we've really been
doing and then being able to uh share
that gift um with y'all and we have a
wonderful leader who does our Bible
studies Maggie um and she's really great
um and so we'll get into sort of that
until we get to into our questions so I
have old school like pen and paper Bible
right here so um I'm really going for it
so um so in both instances in Romans 14
and 1 Corinthians 8 um Paul is writing
two people and he's mainly touching
about two main points um about judgment
and about respect for others so in in
this time it was after um Jesus had died
and the early version of the Christian
church was really getting started and as
you can imagine I mean even now we have
such differing opinions throughout the
church so they also struggle with that
too and so some of the things um that
they were really talking about or about
like food what food was clean and
unclean based on the Old Law new law um
what we should still keep from that what
is okay to get rid of um and then they
also talked about Sabbath a lot too how
many steps should we still be taking the
Sabbath what's holy what's not right and
these are all things I
mean uh theologians theologians they um
still talk about this stuff today um not
necessarily this but about what is
considered holy and Unholy so we have
been just exploring what that means to
us and what that means um and how we can
apply this really into that so um um and
so Paul gets there and he's like guys
this is so irrelevant okay you guys are
focusing on the wrong things and when we
focus on the wrong things we can't focus
on what God wants us to focus on which
is the heart of Christ right so um I'll
read aloud Romans
1417 and then Romans 14:19 and it says
for the kingdom of God is not a matter
of eting and drinking but of
righteousness peace and joy in the Holy
Spirit um and then verse 19 let us
therefore make every effort to do what
leads to peace and mutual
edification okay so um it's they really
get into or Paul really gets into like
what one considers holy won't be the
same as the next person right and so in
order to create this peace or this
Mutual
edification we have to be first of all
very weary of Judgment of of when that
is starting to creep into our hearts um
like it says in Romans 14:4 it says um
who are you to judge someone else's
servant to their own Master's servants
stand or fall they all and they will
stand for the Lord is able to make them
stand and then Paul also asks us to be
weary of our own ego which is something
that I mean obviously we still can
struggle with today um in 1 Corinthians
uh 81 it says now about food sacrificed
to Idols we know that we all possess
knowledge but knowledge puffs up while
love builds up I really like that
so Paul is really saying that we must
look out for one another in love and we
must respect them and he goes on to say
later In this passage that when we don't
respect are the people around us then
we're we're sinning against them and
when we sin against our peers we sin
against Christ right and so it all comes
back to this central idea um and we tend
to shut out people right with different
views um sometimes we can
transition um we how we see them can
transition from a person that Christ
died for to just an idea you know and it
really creates um it loses the humanity
of a person by making them only the idea
so um and by losing that Humanity we
forget that Christ died for all of us
right that we should bring and this fact
should bring unity and not Division and
yet here we are right in in a church
where I'm sure all of you are very
familiar with um division you know and
um um but that's what's so beautiful too
is that Christ challenges us to go
against our human nature of creating
walls and drives us to inclusion okay so
that was my little
recap so um this is but that was all
really really broad so I wanted and what
we've been talking about is how we can
use these big ideas and I mean I think
everyone's like yes we should love
others right like this is good I think
we can all agree on that but then when
it comes to the practical application or
the the personality behind it we get a
little bit lost and that's where we've
really been trying to dig deep and find
what it means with that so by sharing
our personal experiences we're able to
put you know a face behind you know all
of these big ideas that are floating and
help break it down so that we're able to
understand each other better and gain
wisdom from each other so I wrote down a
few questions I'm going to start with
Hank um and my first question I know
I've been talking a lot you get to
finally speak so so question number one
is how do you find peace with people who
have drastically different views from
your
own okay uh well when I meet someone
with different differing values and
opinions I try to find the best way to
just observe and listen to what they
have to say um I feel like the best the
way we should be approaching our outlook
on day-to-day encounter should strive to
be as compassionate and caring as
possible
[Music]
um I found a lot of value in trying to
have a more centered and thoughtful
style of speaking to others um I I think
that just learning the different ways
that people process and think things
through
uh can really strengthen your own
opinions like you can never have a
strong opinion or argument or anything
if you don't know like every angle of
the story um and honestly though it's a
struggle like I try these are the kind
of things I have to work through in my
faith um really the biggest thing is
just being open-minded though uh having
Prejudice is defined
as uh having your judgments being on
someone being based on their Creed their
race or economical background and I feel
like uh often times we rely on that way
too much um but just in in general I
feel like we should just avoid Prejudice
um yeah uh like you can honor your
neighbors opinions and hear what they
have to say but you don't have to always
follow when they're saying
footsteps um I really feel like Jesus
didn't intend for us to be pouring our
energy into evangelizing and converting
everyone we know but really we should be
spending our time trying to just be kind
respectful honest people to just live
our best lives and have
friends I love that thank you so much
Hank um I really like the part of
evangelicalism because um I know that
some of y'all were raised in very
Evangelical backgrounds where it was so
much pressure put on you want to see
this friend in heaven you better you
better be talking to them right now um
the day is coming you know but um I
think it's really important to think
about evangelicalism can also be just
the way that you hold yourself in the
way that you treat others and that's all
sometimes that God needs needs to use um
in order to change
that all right so Eve um do you find it
difficult to separate someone's views
from the person that they are so is this
even possible or are the two inherently
combined um well I think that it's
important when you're talking to someone
to keep in mind that their views might
be different and I think you it's
necessary if you're going to build a
connection with someone to um find a way
to separate the two um with their views
and from them and so
um um I think it's important to put
yourself in diverse groups and to find
ways to allow yourself to connect with
others despite them having different
views from you or you know despite them
disag agreeing with your views or um
anything like that because diversity
opens your mind and it challenges what
you believe in and so I think when
you're talking to someone you need to
remember that whatever they've been
through is going to be totally different
from any of your experiences even if you
know you might have grown up the same
way or you might have grown up with
similar religious backgrounds or
anything but everyone's experience is
going to be totally different and so I'd
say the biggest way to separate
somebody's views from the person that
you know you're really talking to is to
to understand that they are going to be
different and allowing
yourself to really go through you know
what they believe or how they say things
and stuff like that and to go through
and Zone in on who are you talking to
what have you know what are the
backgrounds that they've gone through
why I think if you you need to um what
is it you need to be interested not
interesting you don't need to come out
and say these are my beliefs these These
are My Views yours have to be wrong try
being interested in what they're talking
about you don't have to agree with
everything they're saying but to keep in
mind that what they are saying has a
background what they are saying there's
usually a reason behind people's views
and if you can keep that in mind then
you can recognize the person from what
they're saying in their
views I I know earlier um we were
talking about um one of the reasons why
you you really developed that do you
want to expand like um yeah sure okay so
um I remember when one of my
grandmothers was uh you know dying and
she was going through she was in nursing
homes or hospitals and I would visit
some of the older people in the
hospitals or I would go around and talk
to some others who she was sitting by
things like that and I got into these
conversations where these older people
from the older Generations you know they
don't know everything that I know they
haven't been through what I've been
through and I haven't been through what
theyve been through and I would have
these conversations and they would be so
nice and then they would come out and
just say something that I completely
disagree with but like I could be like
oh no no not anymore that is not how
that works but to them it completely
does like it could be totally different
from what I believe and the whole time
I'm still enjoying it like the whole
time I'm getting to learn from their
perspective and I can see how just
because they think that way there's a
reason for that and because I have you
know I know what I believe in that
doesn't allow it doesn't stop me from
connecting with you know somebody who's
totally different age maybe they you
know have totally different experiences
from a whole different time sometimes I
was able to find all the similarities
despite our differences just connecting
with The Human Experience yeah I I
really love that um I think I think that
human connection is is really what
you're talking about that is able to
humanize a person with sometimes we feel
like it is such an inhumane belief and
then you get to see the person and you
get to connect with them and all of a
sudden it's more than just a belief yeah
all right so um Han um is there a line
between respecting a person and their
values and how do you hold that
line um I think the idea of seeing a
person for who they are rather than just
their beliefs is something we all sort
of know we should be doing but it can be
really difficult sometimes um like we
all think of course I'm not a bad person
I don't speak with bias uh but sometimes
it's just human nature to be flawed that
way um I believe no matter who you are
or what you've done you deserve to be
spoken to like a person like everyone
deserves that so it's really important
to understand that so you can speak like
a mature adult and I'm technically not
an adult but um I want to I want to seem
like one um yeah like I have this friend
uh that I have from one of my classes at
Colin and um he thinks that there's this
he really believes that there's this
strong prevalent Karma system that uh
kind of determines how you'll be
reincarnated and that there's like a
different kind of uh path you might lead
down and uh not to bash that uh I just
personally don't find I think that's
true but um he's also just like a great
guy like he always includes everyone and
he makes sure he speaks kindly to
everyone so I think that yeah respecting
someone's character is really a big
thing but you don't always have to
respect their opinions just at least
honor them
yeah I like that um so the next question
that I'm about to ask
I got very into it and I wrote so many
questions as follow-up questions for
this question but so there's a lot that
I could ask but I'll keep it short for
you Eve um has there ever been a point
where you have distanced yourself from
someone because of their views um is
there a point where you must distance
yourself from people to protect your own
peace
um I would say yeah I have I've come
across people in school or even people
that I've known for like you know much
of my life um and you know we've had
conversations and discussions and there
would be times where you know I would
get hurt from their views they would get
hurt from mine or we would bash heads on
things and sometimes it got to the point
where I just I couldn't do it so I would
rather than just cutting them out maybe
you know I would make boundaries I would
just no longer go over to their house or
I would stop um talking about that stuff
we would you know we could meet casually
in church or casually with friends but
it wouldn't just always be us with each
other you know alone it wouldn't be
something like that and so I have had to
distance myself from people I have had
to draw the boundaries and I think that
when it comes to the point that your
relationship is now harming both of you
then you that's where you need to sit
down and think a is there something that
we could be doing better or something
that we need to talk about to be fixing
that or is it something that this isn't
anything we're willing to comp
compromise on or find a medium so you
have to draw that boundary you need to
draw that line and I think it's
important especially if you're looking
at it with like intentions you know when
it's harming you actively when the goal
is no longer to understand each other's
perspective the goal is now to be right
or the goal is to change the other
person then that's where you really need
to sit down and think okay what is going
on here that either needs to really
change and I really need to sit down and
think about it or maybe I just need to
stop stop doing that I need to cut it
out or you know draw the line draw the
boundary where there I think too much of
anything can be a bad thing too little
of anything can be a bad thing so how
much of that relationship are you
willing to put forward and try to change
if there's too much connection there if
y'all are meeting too frequently if this
um you know whatever yall are
disagreeing on comes up too often then
that's where you need to look at how
much of this should we need to try to
salvage and save fix and how much of
this do we need to let go of of where do
we need to draw that line and I think
that's really important is just finding
the boundaries of how far are we willing
to go I love that um I'll just add in a
little anecdote um um in middle school I
had a very close friend she was in like
almost all of my classes and um as a
person who I've known for a while that I
am queer and I knew in middle school as
well um I also knew that my faith was
something that I wasn't willing to
compromise on either and she was very
Christian and she did not believe the
same thing as me and we were we were
very friendly she's a very intelligent
person she loves the word of God she
loves God and she is just she's just a
well Ed person but I think where I
failed and where I finally realized that
a line needed to be drawn was when I
felt like every time I was talking about
Christianity I was trying to prove to
her that I'm really yes I am Christian
like even though I'm queer like I am
Christian and I was trying to prove
myself so much and prove my
point that I think I lost myself in that
relationship ship and it wasn't
beneficial to me anymore because I
wanted to change her mind and I wanted
her to see me how I feel like I should
be seen and I realized after a few years
that that wasn't going to happen and
instead of instead of proving myself
right I was just harming Myself by
thinking that my existence needs to be
proved right so I I think that was a
time where I really understood like this
is really taking a tool and I know that
it didn't harm her as much as it harmed
me but it it was just it was really hard
too she was a great friend and I I I
relate to that in a lot of ways that
there's some there's some moments where
the Peace of yourself you can't lose
yourself in yeah for sure
in just a relationship in
general um Hank um my question to you is
what are values that you refuse to
compromise on and how do you hold these
values and be sensitive and respectful
to those around you who do
not well ideally I try to have beliefs
that I firmly believe in while also
balancing being more openminded and
allowing of foreign Concepts to me I
definitely believe that c Christianity
is about finding an elevated Lifestyle
by having Christ as your guiding force
but what I really believe above all else
is that we have to try to be kind and
respectful to every everyone we meet um
this is a little weird but if youall
have ever seen the movie everything
everywhere all at once love that movie
so much um that movie is kind of
ridiculous but um but at the beginning
of the movie they to sum it up they
basically say that um since everything
is in the world is so ridiculous and
random and complicated nothing matters
at all but by the end of the movie the
main character Evelyn realizes that uh
because of that we can find because the
world works like that we can find beauty
in every any faucet of life like she
goes to this weird place where like
people have hot dogs for fingers but
then she sees that this like awful lady
who works at the IRS who she thought was
just completely unlovable uh is she
actually has a very meaningful and
complicated relationship with her and it
it's such a good movie but
um that she realizes
that by being kind and respectful in
every encounter we can have more
fruitful lives just in general like it
it really helped me think through how
Christianity in the broader sense
because it's kind of a weird movie but
how it can relate to our lives and how
we can just be better people yeah I I
love that something even and I were
talking about earlier was um how she
finds um Jesus through these connections
that she's able to make with people that
she really believes that um God has made
such diversity um in order to really be
able to view the beauty of the world and
that when we deprive ourselves from um
experiencing that diversity when we when
we guard ourselves off from people who
believe differently than we do we're
depriving ourselves of the Human
Experience like you were saying Hank we
and we deprive ourselves of um being
able to experience that diversity that
God wants for us right so I think in in
thinking of it in a way that we're
missing out can often um help with being
willing and able to um reach
out um I am going to hand it over to
Maggie so she can do the call for the
table but um give a round of Applause to
um Hank and
[Applause]
E they're so great they're so great and
I was just sitting there thinking like
as Han's you know mentioning one of his
values is to just find a way to be kind
and respectful to every single person
I'm thinking of all the conversations
we've had back there on Sunday night and
guys like that is literally how he lives
his life literally how we and we've
watched it even in youth sometimes when
we're like having different opinions or
different people are getting fired up
about things and just this what was that
line you said eve better to be
interested than
interesting that was so good um but I
see that in you Hank all the time on
Sunday nights and just this
intentional effort towards asking
questions and wanting to understand
people better rather than jumping to
your own conclusions and even in the way
that we read scripture I mean we were
doing that verse about knowledge puffing
up versus building uh love building up
he was like puffing up what do you think
in scripture puffed up back in those
days you know I mean let's think of
their perspective what was puffing up
what were they what I mean just the
thoughtfulness is incredible and I'm so
grateful for it so excellent job
moderating that Eden and Eve and Hank
for your courage and willingness to
share and take time on that thank you
guys so
much well we want to move into a time of
communion and I'm going to go ahead and
give our call to the table um this is
one of my favorite Traditions that we've
established here and um I'm honored to
share it
tonight this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and ready for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have little you who have been
here often and you who have not been
here long you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed come because it
is the Lord who invites you and it is
his will that you should meet with him
here come to this the
[Music]
table
Gra
[Music]
hello
oh as we are finishing out our youth
Sunday um a song that I've wanted to do
for a little while it's called meet your
maker by John
Pana patana I don't know um but it's a
song that I heard um just looking
through
Spotify and um it really stuck with me I
I thought every single lyric is
so Tastefully creative and beautiful and
I really I felt it for me and I felt the
the words speak to me and I knew that
the words would speak and bless our
congregation as well um and so I felt
that it was quite important to um be
able to sing a song like this for you
guys so um Michael is going to lead it
for
[Music]
us
Waits on
me you say
come rest and
receive all of those years I was wounded
by
religion you
unwind
me you come
all my
stri you lay your peace over me like
[Music]
think you put an end to my
pretending
show you are the least religious
person that I
[Music]
know you put no
expectations on
[Music]
me you say son I just
want you
[Music]
free all of those years I was wounded by
religion
you
me you come all my
[Music]
oh you lay your peace over me
like
yeah you put an end to my
pretending
show you are the least religious
person that I
know
[Music]
meet your
maker
smiling
bright me your
Sai loves pure
light T the real thing Feast on
life
Jesus
L drink his
wine need
your
smiling
bright
me
saor loves Pure Life
come on and taste
[Music]
the feast on
life
Jesus
L drink his
wine you come up my
stri oh
you lay your peace over me like
[Music]
BL
yeah you put an end to my
pretend show you are the least religious
person that
know you are the least
religious that I
know you are the least religious
person that I
[Music]
know
right uh what we like to do at the end
of our services is thing called the
benediction it's kind of like a prayer
but it's also kind of just a departing
message we'd like to let youall have uh
so if youall like to take a posture of
receiving you can don't that's all right
too all
right you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst day so
as you go into your week ahead with yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with these same gifts of
God to extend love and grace and
unconditional love with everyone you
come in contact with thanks you all have
a good rest of your
[Music]
night you no
more
mying
oh you lay your peace over the me
like
yeah you put an my
pretend